[Music]
so
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle police are closing the
net on the gunman who shot dead a
nine-year-old girl the question is are
britain's cities tangled in gangland
terra after just six months of war just
how do we and the pain in ukraine and
climate lunatics stick themselves to
petrol pumps well one of these
protesters is about to come unstuck
because he'll join me live in the studio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening and a big welcome to piers
morgan unsensed that i'm jeremy kyle now
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell was
supposed to go back to school next week
her teacher said she's a ray of sunshine
a lively soul extremely popular with all
of her classmates
but the truth is that olivia's never
going back to school she was shot dead
in her own home in liverpool on monday
night in front of her own mother and
somebody in liverpool knows who did it
tonight the police are hunting the
killer response with one of the most
sickening and senseless murders this
country has ever seen
the front page of today's liverpool echo
for me says it all if you're keeping
quiet because you'd rather surrender the
city to thugs whose side are you on
they're right
we all know which side we're on and
which side every decent person in
liverpool and this country is on
olivia's devastated family today
described the killer as scum
and said this picture of their beloved
girl will haunt whoever did this forever
now shockingly it's exactly 15 years
since that great city lost another
innocent child to gun crime rhys jones
was murdered aged 11 caught up in
gambling violence he shouldn't even have
known the meaning of
community leaders on merseyside say
liverpool is a changed city now united
by tragedy the city and our country of
yes made progress but another child is
dead tonight dead at the hands of
another gangland criminal's gun and if
that progress and that unity is to mean
anything at all the people surely have
liverpool must find this animal that did
this and bring him to justice i'm
delighted to be joined first up tonight
by former scotland yard detective peter
blexley and security and terrorism
expert will get us but first we're
joined by the auxiliary bishop of
liverpool uh tom williams uh bishop
williams welcome to the show
um
you tell uh a few people you've said
today that the liverpool echo front page
is wrong
they want to sell papers what do you
mean by that
well i think i i saw the interview with
the chief constable at the beginning on
the first day of this
and she came out with that phrase
directed directly to the perpetrators
the echo headline was talking to the
whole city
and i think in some ways it divided the
city and saying you're either for or
against i think the city is a hundred
percent against these criminals i think
the
um
and the comparison with the uh
the child that died 15 years ago
the city is different since then and
that was a watershed but i know in our
schools the school that the child goes
to in within their class there are there
would be possibly
four or five children from different
cultures different backgrounds
the schools are more integrated the the
the people are more integrated if you
look at our hospitals you can see where
most people come from they don't come
from liverpool they come from all areas
around the world bishop williams walk
down the street
williams um i absolutely understand
where you're coming from but the problem
i have is this
um and religion i think should know this
there's a difference here between right
and wrong there's a difference between
good and evil i know all about the
forgiveness right but the truth of the
matter is by writing that page the
liverpool echo are simply saying to a
criminal underworld or a criminal
fraternity do the right thing and i'm
sure there are plenty of schools and
there are plenty of opportunities over
the last 15 years since that poor by
rhys died that advances have been made
but i repeat what i said at the
beginning a child is dead and what i
think the liverpool echo is absolutely
right on it is saying look inside
yourself look at your consciences the
problem is that cities and organizations
governments as well don't like to admit
there's a problem of course you're
saying liverpool's fine but it isn't
with respect bishop williams because a
nine-year-old child was gunned down on
monday and i think what they're saying
is let's deal with it i think their
newspaper headline is responsible and
correct don't you
well i do yes i think because it's
directed to the criminals i think that
it was misleading in the sense that
the
it's a trauma for everybody and
everybody makes the right decision and
the thing when you think about the the
people of that community in particular
um
the the real problems of everyday life
are finding um food on the table uh food
banks and the real everyday problems of
paying for heat and then this absolute
trauma takes place
everybody everybody would be dead
against that and i think it's one of the
most awful things anyone's ever heard of
absolutely peter blexley um we've spoken
many times before um you i know have
spent time in liverpool whenever we do a
story like this people will say over
we're over egging it a nine-year-old
girl shot in her own home what's the
reality the reality is there are a
number of people in liverpool like in
most of our major cities who are beyond
contempt who operate on a completely
different plane to anybody with any
shred of decency and they will take
firearms out onto the streets in order
to settle their scores because they
operate in an illegal world and so you
can't settle a dispute by going to court
for example and having a judgment handed
down you can't get solicitors to
exchange letters what they do is they
arm themselves they're untrained by and
large and they're thugs they are the
scum of the earth and they take firearms
out onto the streets and poor olivia
rest her soul is the victim of that
we'll get a security expert um people
will watch this and they'll go it's
2022.
how
on earth is it so easy in our society to
get a gun you've you've you've brought
one in we have to point out this is a
fake government you've got a lot to say
about this
to say i mean i think people are
probably from what they've seen on tv
and dramas and movies
the reality is that people probably
recognize that firearms can still be
accessed regardless of the fact that the
legislation changed after dunblane's
massacre that obviously firearms were
restricted in terms of certain licenses
however we've seen a huge influx of
weapons coming in from romania from the
balkan states even from the united
states but how the criminals operate is
on different levels you have the very
major organized crime groups they'll be
using the sort of military level of uh
armaments glocks uh berettas those kind
of weapons but then when you scale it
down to the local scumbags and the the
drug dealers they'll be getting
something very similar to this so this
is a fake gun but the point of this is
to point to prove actually how easy it
is to get this it's frighteningly easy
very very easy indeed so this for
example is a gas operated co2 operated
uh pistol now you can buy one of these
for about
150 euros in calais from a shop very
simply you can bring it back with a very
very minor amount of uh work on a on a
lathe and engineering this can become
what we call a far and forget so that is
a weapon where
the criminal the scumbag could use this
for maybe
five to six to seven rounds before it
would actually just collapse
but that's sufficient and that could
kill somebody with a nine millimeter
round absolutely and most nine
millimeter rounds now on the black
market about five pounds per round so
it's not an awful lot of money
peter what are we supposed to do if you
can go to calais and get that no wonder
these gang members are running a mark
what are we supposed to do last night we
talked about you know weapons we talked
about knives there was some footage
today of machetes and leads people going
what are we supposed to do to make our
streets safe if for anything the memory
look on the screen now is is you know
used with machetes in leads just
attacking people
just in broad daylight how do we protect
kids like olivia we could be here for
the entire show talking about what the
police need to do to regain some kind of
control on the streets but what we need
to do immediately is if we know
something if we've heard something we
need to contact merseyside police or
crime stoppers anonymously oh 800 triple
five triple 1 and yesterday i contacted
merseyside police because i've spent a
lot of time in the last three and a half
years because i'm hunting a criminal
from merseyside who's wanted for two
murders so i've immersed myself in the
underworld to an extent of people from
liverpool and one of my sources
contacted me yesterday and they said
they are fairly sure that much of the
recent spate of violence in liverpool is
being orchestrated by a man who is in
prison now interestingly today the man
who was arrested the intended target of
the attack who was shot and went to
hospital he is being recalled to prison
so that might add some credence to what
i was told regardless the police will
listen to gossip rumor title tattle
anything you hear please come on do the
right thing and contact them was the
paper irresponsible gentleman briefly to
the liverpool echo i thought their front
page was spot on the bishop says that it
was divisive what's your response to
that both of you not in the slightest
there is no gray areas here what side
are you on yeah why are you on the side
right scumbags or are you a right
righteous upstanding person who wants to
see olivia's murderer captured but i
think the problem is regardless of the
fact and the morals and the ethics that
people should feel obligated to report
that information through we know with
organized crime peter will know this uh
these individuals will not tell on each
other you know snitching you you don't
believe that anybody will have shot this
guy the abhorrence of this attack
wouldn't even i'm not trying to paint a
picture that criminals have but there is
a there is an unwritten rule am i not
right and saying that criminals when
anything happens to a kid or
is there not any morality at all are you
saying well of all the time i spent in
liverpool a lot of the time i heard this
mantra that people are born and raised
into believing you don't grasp you don't
talk to the police yeah there are
certain things that go beyond the pale
absolutely shooting dead of a
nine-year-old child is exactly such an
example can i bring bishop williams back
in um
we've talked about the front page and i
understand bishop what you're saying
there's a fear that if a newspaper does
that does it then give the message it's
not safe for the kids to go on the
street there's a lot going on but for me
it's absolutely spot on here the people
of liverpool should be doing everything
they can to bring and the family by the
way described this man as scum today
what's your response to that
i agree
yes i agree i'm not i'm not saying that
the echo was wrong i was saying that it
was
the they were quoting what the chief
constable said that to talk to the
families of the vic of the of the
criminals and the people knew relating
to what's happened and what i was saying
was that
is that it was addressed to everyone it
was out of context the context was
addressed directly to the criminals
families and i agree with that
completely and the ones who know them
somebody knows and i agree with exactly
everything you've said about that thank
you very much what i'm saying is that
there's a lot of good people there
absolutely there are a lot of good
people in liverpool we make that point
and i don't think that paper in any way
was implying there wasn't i think what
he was saying the echo and i salute it
was look it's not okay we can't we can't
dress this up
somewhere in liverpool is a man who's
killed a nine-year-old and society in
its entirety in liverpool should do
whatever it can from whatever sector to
bring that scumbag as you quite rightly
said to justice final word from youtube
thank you bishop williams um peter is
this situation last night we talked guns
you saw machetes there and leads it's
just going to get worse and worse what
needs to be done very briefly we need
the police need to patrol the streets
there need to be greater police presence
greater community cohesion greater
neighborhood policing as a priority and
will i mean that yeah the reality we
need to do something about the the
ability for people to just bring weapons
into the country there are just a
variety of different routes where
they're being brought in i mean for one
example a lot of the illegal smuggling
of people coming over rarely do those
ribs come over with
just people it will have contraband and
within that contraband will be things
like weapons
so these weapons will filter through
people can still get them you can even
look at antiquated guns uh like webley's
which although the ammunition isn't
necessarily available these days you can
buy one at a market
for maybe three thousand pounds but it's
not that difficult to make the munitions
for it i have to say you'd watch thank
you both very much today will and peter
you'd watch this and you'd think i don't
know what is happening to this country
there's a cost of living crisis there's
knife crime on the streets and a
nine-year-old
murdered um we appreciate your time next
and uncensored six months of war today
ukraine on the day they celebrate 31
years independence from russia as the uk
pledges another 54 million quid in aid
can public support for ukraine survive
this dreadful economic crisis we're
coming right back on uncensored
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends now it's 31
years to the day that ukraine declared
independence from the soviet union it's
also six months to the day that russia
invaded in a bloody but so far failed
attempt to take that independence away
with crisis and costs everywhere we turn
at home you'd be forgiven for writing
off ukraine's suffering as a quarrel in
a far away land somebody else's struggle
after all we're all worried about food
prices uh
fuel prices energy shortages but
remember they're all the same thing
they're all tied to ukraine's fight for
survival and the ukrainians fighting for
their freedom are also fighting for the
fundamental principles of our free world
that's why boris johnson returned to
keeve today restating britain's
unwavering support
if we're paying in our
energy bills
for the evils of vladimir putin
the people
of ukraine
are paying in their blood
and that's why we know we must stay the
course
but despite the billions in aid and
support from around the world there is
absolutely no end to sight insight to
ukraine's misery and in a nutshell this
is why russia is illegally occupying
swathes of ukrainian territory killing
thousands of ukrainians in the process
if ukraine gives up this land in any
kind of peace deal putin will simply
regroup and then come back for more
president zielinski told this show
exactly why that can never happen
we are not prepared to exchange or trade
the territory of the independent state
of ukraine
we have no right for this first of all
we are the government because this land
belongs to ukrainian people
and sad news this evening this just in
more civilians killed in ukraine
president zielinski says
15 people have died and another 50 have
been injured in a russian rock strike a
rocket strike on a train station so with
no pause in the misery and no imaginable
end to the war tonight we're asking how
long is this going to go on joining me
now and i'm delighted to have a kiera
ruddick a ukrainian member of parliament
and tobias elwood chair of the defense
select committee in the united kingdom
kira i'll start with you i've i've said
this for many months one of the things
that concerns me is that this conflict
which is so horrendous
the best way to put this i'm not sure
but becomes
it's happening and we get on with our
lives and we forget and we must never
forget these atrocities what
six months in on the day of independence
what is the feeling in the ukraine from
your own people
we are happy that we are alive
and we know that being alive and still
fighting is actually a sign
that
everybody was wrong about us you
remember the six months ago uh most of
the intelligences of the world were
saying that we don't stand a chance and
we will fail in like a week or two
and it's six months and we are still
standing and we are fighting and we're
here to tell that we are not giving up
on our territories and we are here to
say
that we will be fighting till we win
we know that it's incredibly dangerous
that it will become new normal for the
world what's happening in ukraine right
now and this is why we are calling for
everyone to
help us to make this push
to give us more weapons to give us more
support because you see how effective
and efficient we are with it
and when we are not facing russians
empty-handed we are able to make the
progress we are able to win our
territories back so this is our aim this
is our goal and this is where we are at
the six months of war and 31 years of
independence
today of course boris johnson came on
independence day um announcing 54
million pounds in in aid if i can bring
in tobias elwood tobias welcome to the
show um
probably a tricky question but one i
know you'll be prepared to answer
um i think that anybody in the world
that would look at what's going on in
ukraine knows it's not just ukraine's
war it's the world's war but when you
consider back home
the daily strife uh the cost of living
crisis people unable to pay their bills
unable to to do very obvious things and
many families are going to the wall
do you worry
do politicians worry that people will go
it's in a faraway land i i'm struggling
i'm not saying that's right but do you
have concerns that i don't know war
fatigue could set in mentally for people
yes and that's absolutely right right i
first met kiritik uh exactly uh six
months and four days ago uh in kiev uh
just prior to the invasion nobody
believed that uh russia was going to
invade the ukrainians believed it i
believed it but everybody was in denial
and they thought well this is a far-off
place what's it got to do with us
they're not a member of nato then let's
lead them to their own devices
we now recognize that this is just about
ukraine this is something far bigger
going on this is russia re-exerting
itself of putin wanting to reinforce his
slavic vision and influence in the
eastern part of europe if we don't put
this fire out in ukraine it will spread
elsewhere and there is a direct uh link
between what is happening here with that
cost of living crisis which i'm pleased
you made the connection with you know
oil and gas prices have gone up here as
have food because in part because of
what's going on in ukraine we need to
lean into this i'm pleased our prime
minister is there committing more money
but every day the ukrainians spend about
40 million
pounds on ammunition 40 million pounds a
day so this isn't going to last very
long at all we need greater political
resolve to look putin in the eye and say
we've had enough of this we're going to
stand up to you completely agree if i
can go back to kira um
what would your message be of course
it's it's very interesting for me
because i'm sat here doing a program in
the united kingdom and the cost of
living crisis is central to so many
people's lives and yet you're right we
look at what's going on in your country
and it pales into insignificance
absolutely but what would you say a
ukrainian who's trained to to have a gun
who's a member of parliament who's
fighting literally personally to protect
your country
what would your message be to people
watching this in the united kingdom who
think
we can't afford our own lives why should
we be giving money away what would you
say to them kira
first of all i would say thank you for
your support
and thank you tobias because you were
the first one of uh
western politicians who did believe in
what we were saying we will never forget
this but coming back to
the people look we are comparing the
situation that we are having right now
with the
energy crisis and
uh cost of living with some ideal
situation and hoping that things could
be as they were at the past but they
cannot putin started ramping up prices
way before the war in ukraine started it
was like november or even october and i
do not think that if ukraine loses
putin will come back to uh to dropping
them and will become a lovely person who
will forget about his dream of
conquering the world does anybody even
think that he will um he will change his
behavior if ukraine fails so we should
compare
the situation that we have right now
when there is indeed a ramp up in prices
there is indeed a very complicated
situation to the situation that would be
much worse
and that would be if you claim loses
because then uh
then the energy bills would be 10 times
higher then the price of the food will
be 10 times higher and then the
migration crisis that we're seeing right
now would be absolutely different it
will be on tremendous level on your show
you were talking about guns we rate now
give up up to
seven million of guns that only only the
ones that i know in ukraine what would
happen if all those people uh will will
have to move to europe
what will happen with uh was the general
strategy so when somebody says that we
don't have they they don't have a plan
on how to resolve situation to help
ukraine win
i have a question how are you going to
live if we lose
absolutely that's absolutely unpleasant
i completely agree and i think that
international support for ukraine must
continue and and and we must be
steadfast in our support and one of the
reasons we wanted to do this on
independence day was to make tobias the
point to people that that it it is not
going away it does affect us all it
might as we said be in a far away land
but it will impact on so many parts of
our life can i just finish tobias by
saying um we know um boris johnson was
there today uh on independence day 54
million we know that boris johnson will
cease being the british prime minister
in a couple of weeks he has built very
close ties with zelensky and in fact
some of his even his critics said that
the job that he's done for this country
in ukraine has been one of the
highlights of his premiership do you
believe that that closeness that
concentration on helping ukraine will
continue under the new prime minister
and will you be pushing for that tobias
uh absolutely there is a bond that's
developed between
our two nations which is second to none
we've stepped forward more than other
countries have in nato i have to say uh
straight from the start in supporting uh
our friends uh in ukraine but more needs
to be done this is where you need
international leadership i'm afraid i
have to say that we're not seeing it
from britain from germany from france or
from the united states yes we're giving
operational equipment but we need
strategic analysis and direction of
travel that shows that we have a policy
direction to stand up to russia we had a
speech last week but from putin he made
it very clear that the global baton of
leadership must now be handed away from
the west to a non-west nation he was
implying russia and indeed china that is
the era of insecurity a new decade of
insecurity that we now face this is 1937
all over again and we need to wake up
couldn't agree with you more uh kira
thank you so much indeed in ukraine
tobias elwood uh both from the talk and
actually to to me uh there's a
similarity between that situation in
ukraine and our first story right and
wrong good and evil it's particularly
obvious to anybody with the brain cell
that putin will not stop and has to be
prevented from taking over that
independent sovereign nation because it
will impact on all of our lives next on
uncensored goodness me princess
pinocchio's latest podcast bombshell she
says baby arch's nursery caught fire
during their recent tour of south africa
the heater
in the nursery caught on fire
everyone's in tears everyone's shaken
and what do we have to do
go out and do another official
engagement but does the story check out
i'm joined by someone who was actually
on that tour and disagrees back in free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
right welcome back so hold on to your
seats my friends meghan markle's in the
headlines for stretching the truth again
also tonight on the show the pope is
catholic and bears do defecate in the
woods from where it's pumped directly
onto britain's beaches
yes meg said it again she's regaled the
listener to her new podcast with the
terrifying story of how son archie
narrowly escaped a fire in his bedroom
on a royal tour of south africa
the heater
in the nursery caught on fire
everyone's in tears everyone's shaken
and what did we have to do
go out and do another official
engagement
despite being shaken and in tears she
and harry bravely and i mean bravely
resumed their duties but it turns out
that archie wasn't even in the room when
it happened and royal sources today told
the press that they don't even recall
any fire at all merely an overheating
heater you try saying that now this
isn't the first time megan's face claims
that the truth isn't necessarily the
truth our investigative units and a top
team of data journalists have produced
this forensic visualization of megan's
fibs she famously told oprah she married
prince harry intimately and in secret
days before their televised bash in
windsor the archbishop canterbury said
oh no she didn't megan claims the royal
family took away her passport leaving
her a princess trapped in a tower but
investigation by her own the son found
she took at least 13 foreign holidays
during the period in which she was
apparently grounded megan also claimed a
member of the royal household expressed
concerns about the i can't do this the
color of her unborn child's skin while
she was pregnant but she's never been
able to say who it was and she says she
barely knew anything about the royal
family the nose can't get any bigger
before she met harry friends have said
she was a royal fanatic who visited bp
as a child and wanted to be diana 2.0
there you go my friends lies damn lies
and the dusting of sussex or as the
queen yourself put it recollections may
vary joining me now is robert jobson
royal editor at the evening standard in
tonight's panel esther craig here i
can't wait former labour adviser my good
friend richard powerstade welcome people
hello thank you um
uh let's start with you robert yeah um
why is this woman such a divisive
character why does she generate
the column inches the comments i mean
she seems to annoy
slash
excel in people's brains so much why
i mean i think that the oprah winfrey
interview didn't help i mean that was
pretty awesome we went through the
pinocchio stories there but i think it's
i was talking about the guys in it if we
all landed in la tomorrow i think there
would be a difference in the way things
be fair the way we address issues but
yeah as i say i was in south africa on
that okay the the
the foreign office of issued a statement
saying that all our residencies meet the
requirements health and safety
requirements um tried contacted all the
three people that were the aides there
today and none of them would answer the
any questions because unlike this
program i think that the palace is
somewhat censored when it comes to
meghan markle they're a bit scared of
her they're a bit scared of what they
should say about her as well because the
reactions
um but i was there i i don't recall any
fire engines i mean we didn't get the
story obviously we were pretty rubbish
in a job but there were no stories and
the whole of the south african press
didn't cover this incident there were no
fire engines called to the residents you
know
we have to ask questions about that but
she's saying that you know it was a
smoke was in the room
i tell you what my issue is richard just
to bring you in a sec because i know
what my mate is
i was asking the crew earlier one of the
cameras said i i i sort of feel she gets
bad press but my argument will be
she comes across as lacking in ingenuous
she why wasn't this said at the time it
all seems to be this orchestrated
campaign to
to gain
popularity which i sort of want to tell
her she's never going to regain you've
taken 118 million
be quiet i mean it seems to me that that
you could say something quite similar
with quite a lot of different members of
the royal family yeah um look i i think
uh
she's not got very many very interesting
things to say i feel quite sorry for her
because i think she's been obsessively
uh kind of slightly creepily obsessed
over by the british media do you think
she thought do you think she came from
california that different lifestyle and
thought i'm going to change the world
i'm going to modernize the monarchy i'm
going to save harry from the misery that
he's going through i'm going to be this
beacon of light and very quickly people
went well i'm not buying what you're
saying love i mean if she thought that
then she was incredibly naive but she
might quite reasonably have thought that
you know there's one prince who's going
to become head of state who thinks it's
fine to undermine our democracy and sort
of you know what what was he doing
taking taking enormous donations from
somebody who his chief aide then makes
sure this saudi billionaire gets
citizenship and a knighthood from the
queen i mean it's really really ranked
that's what one of them is doing the
other one's friends with pedophiles and
frankly is probably not telling the
truth about it she might quite
reasonably have thought that she wasn't
going to be the most unpopular member
let's get a crystal ball
we can't yeah listen you have a right to
european that's what talk is all about
isn't it i mean
maybe she has a point is it not the way
esther that she does this to me it's so
i was i don't even know what the right
word is even the name of that goddamn
yes just not lacking in anything genuine
i just don't buy it but i think that's
that was her biggest frustration being
part of the royal family she couldn't
curate her image for the public that's
the problem she had because i think when
you when you she says she didn't grow up
in tabloid culture fine but there is a
way you can manipulate media in the u.s
to try and sort of prepare a certain
image but when you're part of the firm
your first sort of duty is your duty to
the firm and to the country it's not
about curating the perfect image of
yourself i completely agree that you
know there are members of the royal
family that are less palatable i've
always advocated that prince andrew
should be kept in the catacombs of paris
um that doesn't change anything that
doesn't change the fact that meghan
markle is completely unlikable and the
thing is that she can only milk two
years in the royal family for so long
what exactly does what else does she
have to say what else what else is there
to have you know torturous life as part
of the royal family there's nothing else
my point is this and i absolutely
support my old man worked for the royal
family for 41 years and he always said
and you talk about the part of the firm
he always said um that anybody passed
the queen mother and the queen has
systematically used the press for their
own ends whenever they've wanted it he
included charles danner and all of all
of the rest of them and he doesn't think
that mystique will ever return so maybe
we're being unfair to meghan markle and
maybe richard has the point that
actually if they looked at themselves
uh not william and kate i think but but
they're all as bad are a lot of them as
bad as each other why does she get if we
balance those viewpoints i think he's
coming from a different angle i think
the royal family do a terrific job for
this country
and i think that when you see what the
prince of wales has done in terms of his
you know the amount of well and the
queen and the amount of work they do on
behalf of the government i think that's
the point we seem to forget is that the
foreign officers ask him to do this what
upsets a lot of people i think is that
megan was around for
two minutes really you know not long
enough she didn't give it long enough i
think she could have done a terrific job
in the commonwealth she would have given
diversity a real plus i think that
there's a lot of things that she could
have done and he just gave up on it and
i just don't this lady's story she was
forced to go out on this job i very much
doubt anyone that would have thought
being a fool so let alone her own
husband to make a go on this job if she
was that distraught about her no i mean
if there was a bar in my house there's
no way i wouldn't i wouldn't be doing
this show i'd have been at home exactly
exactly but
what was it it wasn't firebomb as well
it's quite interesting what esther says
about likability i absolutely take it
but i go back to the old man and he says
that when the queen dies and we've had
this discussion before he doesn't
believe the royal family or the monarchy
will ever be the same again now a lot of
people would disagree with that but the
queen i think will never we will never
appreciate what an amazing woman until
she's no more but but are they as bad as
each other is it her like but is it the
way she goes about stuff that's what it
is i don't think that the royal family's
success until this moment has been based
upon likability like that is not it's
hard work and graph by the queen right
exactly and you know what i was saying
but you know i think meghan markle's uh
podcast sounds quite boring well you
know what the queen is quite boring in a
pretty impressive way right that's 70
years of her life but i don't know what
see i disagree with her i don't think
the queen's boring at all when she what
she does and what she did when we really
needed her during the pandemic when
boris johnson had covered when the
prince was coming down with she came in
with that that statement which great
created a sense of calm yeah when the
when the politicians couldn't have done
that when you had boris jimmering away
and he's two experts about what we
should be doing what we should be doing
showed us various graphs from school
about covered it was the queen's words
you know we will meet again and prince
he's not going to be able to do that
but i think that the prince of prince of
wales will be able to draw people
together i think that what jeremy's
saying is right but he is
it's a terrifically hard working man
somebody i think yes you'll believe it
okay there are has anything illegal been
done with this donation from charity no
otherwise he'd be under investigation
with the police so that isn't the case
do you think that you think the place
would be do you think the police would
be investigated
of course they did of course they
weren't there they investigated prince
andreas what we're going to say i was
going to say that i think one thing that
has
we all respect about the queen is her
sense of duty and aside from the whole
likability argument which we can go back
and forth it's the fact that meghan
markle never showed a sense of duty and
that was the biggest issue i think you
know and i i don't necessarily blame her
because celebrity culture in the us is
very different right there's no real
sort of there's no
equivalent of the royal family in the
u.s you become a celebrity you get rich
you donate money and you're a god right
in the uk in the uk it's completely
different you know there's a real this
is why piers morgan's in america at the
moment
to regain his god staff yeah absolutely
but you know you have that you have to
be able to read the room you have to
have some respect for the british public
there's certain things you just don't do
and i don't think she completely
understood i think it's really
interesting because i can see all points
i i get what you're saying richard
actually about if you look at if you
point a mirror at the rest of them
actually there's a lot of them who
aren't great i think i think you though
robert have a really good point as well
she was here two minutes people have
done 70 years yes they'll have made
mistakes but it's about duty
i mean look at prince
you know incredible servant to the crowd
incredible servant to the queen there's
a strength and stay and i just think
that that just was such a he must have
been looking at this but towards the end
of his life and thinking what on earth
what a shambles what's all the you know
what's all the grasping
we don't have
go on this is a grown-up country we
should have a grown-up political system
why do we have this american why do we
have this fairytale nonsense this is a
constitutional monarchy and a
parliamentary embarrassing where are we
growing up
the american democracy where you get
biden and what do you want president
i mean we could look over at europe but
all these incredibly successful
democracies mps if they wanted to get
rid of the monarchy we have by the way
got rid of the monarchy once before then
the mp's their system will sort that out
and work out my friends as i draw to a
close how much the american president
cost the british over the american
people and how much the monarchy brings
into british coffers but will agree to
disagree meghan markle might be in your
heart you might believe she's the
greatest thing since sliced bread or you
might believe as piers morgan once said
princess pinocchio only believes what
she says to self right next and
uncensored they're at it again this time
the eco zealots from just top oil stick
themselves to petrol pumps and they're
in this studio now hide the glue back in
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back my friends now barely a
week passes without eco fanatics
sticking their noses into our morning
commute usually by sticking themselves
to bits of our roads today protesters
from just stop oil damaged fuel pumps
and glued themselves to a service
station forecourt along the m25 surrey
police tell us they've arrested at least
20 people yesterday the same group
caused chaos at old depots by staging
sit-down protests already this year
they've disrupted the bafta awards
that's not such a bad thing in the
british grand prix as well as sticking
themselves to various priceless works of
art joining me now is just stop all
protester alex de conning i hope that's
right and former top gear presenter
steve berry alex i don't have a go i
want to get straight to the point um i
have an issue with with this but i want
to ask you a question what does just
stop oil mean briefly
uh basically the government are trying
to push through another 40 new fossil
fuel facilities and we're demanding that
there should be no new oil licenses in
the uk because we have eight years in
reserve which is more than enough time
to have a fair transition to renewable
energy and to make sure that oil workers
are re-skilled and treated properly
right so here's what i'm going to say to
you how old are you i'm 24. i don't want
to sound like your dad but here's what
i'm going to say to you if you were 57
young man right yeah and you had a
family and you had a mortgage and you
had to go to work and you had an energy
crisis was about to [ __ ] you
financially would you be sitting in a
road or would you be slightly hacked off
if these eco zealots or whatever you
call them were making it impossible for
you to carry on with your job i don't
mean to be disrespectful in any way i'm
being honest every time i get somebody
from just stop oil they're barely out of
nappies no disrespect where
why
you don't have any experience of the
real world it's just it's a bunch of
unwashed students giving it large you're
stopping people from doing going about
their daily lives man unwashed okay um
first of all we have many age ranges
i've been arrested next to people who
are um you say that with pride i've been
arrested why
because this is the kind of action that
we need to take we're in a climate
emergency do you not realize how
important the situation yes i do but
you're not gonna like what i'm gonna say
and you're gonna say i'm gonna i don't
know what steve says we're in a climate
emergency there are people watching this
who cannot pay their bills they cannot
eat their houses they cannot feed their
kids and do you know what i'm going to
say to you yeah leave that a minute and
concentrate what's now i'm not saying to
leave that a minute the cost of living
crisis is very closely related to the
climate crisis we could be fixing both
at the same time no we could be
insulating homes which saves almost half
on people's energy bills i didn't cut
the green levy i'd cut v80 on fuel and i
i'm not saying energy bills are 2.5
billion pounds higher than they should
be here's another green policies have
been scrapped over the last decade
here's another we subsidize public
transport which we were talking about
before we arrived on the show that would
save people a fortune on transportation
costs as well as i'm not disagreeing
about the fact that there are issues i'm
talking about how you do it and now
bringing steve briefly really appreciate
what you're saying
do we i think it'd be great to be that
young and idealistic i was like when i
was his age combat jacket placard band
the bomb down with this sort of thing
vegetable right from peace but it's not
patronizing what i'm saying you're right
but you're titled his opinion but you
are look there seem to be two there seem
to be two groups there's there's nice
well presented well spoken yeah there is
middle class young people like that and
then there's
people in their 50s and 60s who look
like they went to the public sector
retired early on a board watching
antiques road trip and tipping point so
they want something to do
they're asking for stop oil oil is
stopping but there's going to be
fossil fuel facilities
but there's going to be a transitional
period look at the population the
transitional people should start right
now look we have eight years ago it was
40 degrees in london a few weeks ago 40
degrees it was that in 1976 you weren't
around to experience it
do you want to see the grass i can show
you the grass can i say can i just jump
in just generally for one reason and i
and i've said my piece and fair play to
you've said yours do you not think
there's a more constructive way and i go
back to it and i never get answered this
than ruining well you what you do is you
stick yourselves to these things and you
make it impossible for people to get on
with their lives why are you not talking
sense as you've actually spoken hands in
the air i've learned more from you in
two minutes than all of those dullards
sticking themselves to whatever and
making our lives more difficult that's
the point i'm making but sadly we would
not get on shows like these if it wasn't
for stuff like this i'd have you on you
didn't have to stick yourself to
anything i'm waiting for that hand move
that hand oh it's fine we're all right
no but i'm thinking i appreciate that
but then please invite me back next time
instead of having to resort to this is
the wrong target instead of
inconveniencing hard-working pieces they
try and get to work or school or
wherever they've got to go why don't
they glue themselves to the yachts of
these super rich guys that are making
all this money which says that why don't
you do that and i'd say well i'll tell
you why because they might have to go
outside the uk and then they find the
sort of policing where they don't ask
for your pronouns first they give you a
crack with a stick which is virtually
everywhere else inside the uk look what
happened in italy when they tried
pulling this sort of routine people not
the police just got out of the car
and dragged them out
i will never forget that woman right in
the the range rover who couldn't get to
the hospital with a guy i'm just asking
you alex i'm not you can't take stuff
do you understand her frustration with
you and your friends of course i
understand so why don't you do it
differently why are you not getting the
people on the show who have been
disrupted because train tracks are
spontaneously combusted because heathrow
runways have been melted so flights
couldn't take off and flash flood so
people couldn't get to work in that way
why haven't you got people on the show
who because i've only got two minutes
left and i've got you on
no but you're always focusing on this
kind of disruption and not the other
kinds of things
well you say we're focusing on
disruption my friend that's because you
and your supporters and the only way to
stop us and also to stop the other kinds
of disruption from the climate crisis is
for the government to stop issuing new
fossil fuels so you won't stop doing
what you're doing until the government
does that is that what you're saying
exactly that's what i'm saying thank you
final word you always do it in the
southeast of england come to salford try
it up there see how you get online you
you got arrested in newcastle my
favorite city you were left shaking
after being forcibly dragged away yeah
so we were very surprised by the
response i'm doing my phd in green
hydrogen production at newcastle
university and i just want to point out
that there are so many solutions that i
found through this that it was not being
used we have these well i'll tell you
what come back on the show right come
back on the show and spend time talking
to me about that but i will never change
and i mean that genuinely because fair
play to you but my my issue is is that
is the disruption the disrespect i'm not
listen you might have a very good point
but i think you have to understand that
people are really struggling and i think
that right now right now
they don't look kindly i'm saying if you
want traction from your argument we're
not trying to find it
i'm not trying to win the x factor here
it's not a popularity contest we are
doing this because we need things to
change fair enough history has shown
that in order to get the kind of radical
change that we need at the time scale we
have this is the solution women did not
get the vote by voting on it no they
threw themselves in front of a horse
final word from you steve berry
wrong target target these rich fat cats
don't not working people
really really appreciate it and that is
an open offer and i mean that man to man
i really hope to come back on this
absolutely thank you very much very much
for having me steve thank you alex thank
you just a quick word by the way gcse
results tomorrow morning my aides
getting hers fingers crossed to
everybody who's giving this i know it's
a very worrying night but you've done
your best and fingers crossed you get
the good result that is it from me
tonight we're back tomorrow at eight
o'clock and don't forget wherever you
are or whatever you're doing uh piers
morgan made me promise as he sits in the
south of france judging by his instagram
eating prawns whatever you make you're
up to make sure it's unsensitive that's
a big tick have yourselves a great night
that's been me back tomorrow night see
ya tara
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers allen in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm kate partridge the
family of nine-year-old olivia pratt
corbell who was shot dead in liverpool
have branded her killer scum while a
police manhunt for the gunman is ongoing
it's after 35 year old joseph knee was
arrested in connection with the incident
knee was the intended target of the
shooting after breaching the terms of
his early release from prison
boris johnson made a surprise visit to
kiev earlier and offered his
congratulations to the ukrainian people
on their independence day today also
marks six months since russia's invasion
began public gatherings have been banned
in kiev over fears of an attack
and a courts heard how benjamin mendy
told one of his eight alleged victims
don't worry it's small before sexually
assaulting her mendy denies all charges
against him that's all for now we'll
have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you